léa salamé qui se retire de la scène
médiatique j'aime ou j'aime pas alors
j'aime qu'elle se retire après blêmir
pourquoi vous pourquoi vous aimez pas
parce qu'elle me gave
voilà donc en fait c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vous c'est une bonne
nouvelle
et en plus il ya un truc qui me la rend
petit peu plus sympathique en revanche
c'est que j'aime bien qu on s'efface
derrière un homme brisé
c'est mon petit convenir déjà trois
méthaniers est ce que c'est que cette
arnaque oui ça plaît parce que là ce
moment je suis leur ticket je n'aime pas
oui ça se voit ouais ouais non j'étais
un soin visage aujourd'hui
bah ouais bah ça vous a fait une bosse
ici bien content c'est par contre quand
vous êtes cogner mais bon non mais je
déteste que la fed discours féministe ya
derrière ce qu au delà je me retire mais
j'en fait un buzz pour qu'on parle de
moi parce que j'ai une prétention
incroyable mais juste et toi tu pars où
tu pars pas elle aurait dû rester
elle en a fait un acte féministes les
femmes en 2019 cerveaux des des hommes
et tous à énoncer grosse échéance est
elle actuellement la journaliste qui est
le plus le melon sur toute l'antenne
elle a créé le buzz au d'isabelle est
d'accord avec vous pour une fois mais
oui c'est vraiment gros test match mc se
retire toute sphère médiatique et autour
est totalement inutile pour moi elle se
retire à serrer les poings barralon 27
mai c'est pas un drame mais alors bon il
ya 20 mois qui a réagi il s'est montré
assez critique envers cette décision
voilà moi je kiffe yann moix et darkaoui
non c'est catastrophique que ça envoie
une image de la femme d'une soumission
totale
l'homme va au charbon et elle reste
faire la vaisselle
je trouve ça absolument inouïe qu'elle
le fasse c'est elle se sacrifie et mon
avis pour pas grand chose j'ai beaucoup
d'amitié d'affection pour rafa
glucksmann maintenant je pense que la
capacité qu'il a à faire bouger les
choses dans ce registre est nul qu elle
ne se donne pas non plus toute
l'importance qu'elle n'a pas aussi je
respecte beaucoup je les adore mais ne
te fais pas si petit qu'il n'est pas si
grand ce conseil est valable à la fois
pour raphaël est pour l'heure que
j'adore tous les deux mais faut pas que
j'ai l'impression que les deux ont
gentiment pris le melon faites-vous
compris ce que veut dire mais il dit les
buy et disent que tout le monde pense en
vrai alors c'est vrai nous avions eu
vent du nord
par ailleurs là où il a raison c'est
qu'effectivement ils n'ont pas un
cerveau pour 2 il me semble que léa
salamé et suffisamment corps ticket pour
être capable de faire une interview qui
se bat pas
à l'aune de ce que pense son mari elle
est capable de réagir dont son mari à
chaque fois quand c'est une femme parce
que son mari death prend une décision
politique et publique elle peut très
bien aussi de se présenter à la
direction du club d'échecs de
[Rires]
saint-adrien la scène médiatique et bien
vous avez raison
bataj présente toi alors suite à la
décision de sa compagne raphaël
glucksmann s'est exprimé ils étaient
très touchés donc c'est lui qui va
représenter le parti socialiste aux
élections européennes elle peut pas
rester à décision elle elle décide que
sa déontologie du journaliste le fait
d'être au dessus au dessus de tout
soupçon cc c'est le plus important
mais moi personnellement ça me pose un
problème ça me pose un problème parce
que je sais très bien que et enfin que
l'on verrait et physiquement en 2019 on
peut pas considérer qu'une femme en fait
elle assez ensoleillé et qu'en plus je
sais comment elle fonctionne et je sais
comment on n'a même pas les mêmes avis
sur les choses c'est un acte d'amour
incroyable parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
a toujours placé son travail au dessus
tout au dessus de tout dans sa vie de
seconde elle lui donne par un non mais
je m'excuse
[Applaudissements]
l'iphone est plus clair ouais ouais mais
il est ému c'est sa meuf et trois mois
prend 3 - de rtt
alors là bas sur les poteaux on est en
train de perdre qualité novelli et enfin
de décéder sa malle vers agirc ali moi
je pense qu'il existe des buzz a real
c'est une bosseuse c'est juste pour le
buzz donc jamais vu ce qu elle pense
aussi